seth steve congratulations you guys have
made it to this final round of
competition and that means we're sending
you back to your home forges to recreate
this iconic weapon from history
napoleon's saber
good luck blade smiths we'll see you in
four days
i'm back home at my home forge in goache
mississippi
and i'm going to be working on napoleon
saber round one
i let the pressure get to my head and i
didn't meet parameters
so i'm really gonna have to make sure
that i don't get flustered
and make this thing beautiful and
functional as well
i decided to go with 5160
it is a great spring steel but i'm
looking at the blade
and i think i have a little too much
curvature
i was at the three inch mark so i had to
put it back in the forge
and knock it down i knocked it down a
little too far
time to go back in the forge again it's
kind of like a cat and mouse game
it's a little over an inch well
it's just one of those things it's back
and forth and back and forth and i'm
finally
got it
i'm back at home i'm in my comfort zone
the lack of power tools
could put me at a disadvantage so i need
to plan wisely
[Music]
i've got a nice bar of 5160. it's going
to make a good strong sword
it is super hard to hammer
and i'm gonna have to just get after it
and know that day one is gonna be tough
but i'm gonna have to suck it up we're
gonna be here a while
for the pommel i'm using one inch solid
uh
hot rolled steel i've got a lot of metal
to move
and i'm a little bit worried that i
might not get all this metal
moved today
finally i've got this thing where i need
it
we're at the correct length the correct
thickness today
is a success all right feels pretty good
it's the start of day two it's time to
move on to the heat treatment of the
blade
the idea is is to get as even a heat
on this as uh possible and like napoleon
i will divide and conquer
i don't feel no ticks i don't feel no
tings
i have a hardened blade it's time to do
a
rough fit up of the wood part of the
handle and the pommel
and this is going to taper down
to brass that's the idea
now is it going to work i go to try to
bend it
and it bends just a little bit on the
first go round and i'm like all right
all right this looks like it's going to
work i go to try to bend it
one more time oh
broke the brass that was my biggest
piece of brass that i could have used
for it
so that's kind of down the drain at this
point i don't really know what to do
but i look down at the floor and i'm
looking at the deer antlers that i have
and i notice the curvature in them no
one says that it has to be made out of
brass
copper or gold as long as i hollow it
out
and it has a nice taper to it and it
fits the hand
why not a deer antler
we got a fit today we'll be quenching
the blade
the quench is a moment that can go
horribly wrong i've got to get the
entire blade
one nice uniform temperature it's not
going to be very easy in the short
boards that i have so what i plan on
doing
is building an oven at the back side of
the ford
this oven's going to keep my point warm
but not let it cool off
should be a good help so i've got the
forge turned up as high as it'll go
i've got my little butane torch in the
front
all right here we go
we're straight the beautiful sound of a
skating bile
hard hard hard how'd the quench go
quench went good i think no bends no
warps
got it out file skated on it i'm ready
to see it finished
give me a little while we'll have that
done okay okay thanks for checking
love you
the closer and closer i get towards the
final shape of it i'm feeling it in my
hand
kind of twirling it a little bit not
quite as good as doug
markita will be doing but feels good in
the hand
becoming a fortune fire champion would
be a great way to show people that
i can do this and would be one step
closer
to me to becoming a full-time bladesmith
because this is the
dream right here i am done
i couldn't be happier it's the last day
i tempered the blade yesterday in the
oven but i felt like
maybe half did the job so i want to
temper my blade with my torch to give me
peace of mind
there is risk involved in a torch temper
which means that i
could lose the hardness of the blade i
should see a nice
blue up toward the top and a little
straw moving down toward the
middle of the blade i think that seth
is going to try to design a blade that's
going to be much
prettier and sharper than mine but i
sacrificed a little bit of sharpness to
get a little more meat behind
that cutting edge i'm in at about three
pounds right now
it's gonna cut but it's not gonna be a
razor blade
it doesn't feel horribly heavy it really
doesn't put it right there
there's one more thing to do
it will keep
all right bladesmiths to find out what
kind of lethal damage your weapon will
do
i'm going to deliver slashes and thrust
on this big carcass
seth you're up first you ready for this
let's do it
all right seth from the snodler to the
trotter every cut with this as you can
see
offers a very deep lacerating
cut the only issue is that your blade
did pick up a little bit of a bend
but overall sir with the way this weapon
moves and feels
it will kill thank you very much good
job all right stephen your turn you
ready sir
yes sir
[Music]
uh
all right steven let's talk about your
saber here it's a heavy
unbalanced sword the minute you pick up
it wants to pull straight down
it's hard to wield but the weight of
your sword here
will definitely bash in and cut
so it will kill thank you oh bladesmiths
a saber is supposed to be a sturdy
weapon
so let's see how yours hold up on our
strength test the ram skull
chop now i'm going to take each of your
sabers
and with no mercy it all bash them into
this ram skull
it's not only going to test the overall
strength of your knife but the heat
treat on your edge
now i don't really care what your swords
do to the skulls i want to see what the
skulls do to your swords
now seth you're up first you're ready to
go swing it good
[Music]
all right seth your edge held up but we
do have a bigger bend in the blade than
we had before
your guard is now mobile
and both of your bolsters came off as
well so this mechanical connection right
in here
failed but the connection between your
blade and your handle is still sturdy
you took some damage but you survived
good job thank you sir
steve after seeing that how you feel
i don't know let's see
there you go they had heat treatments
well steve we obviously have a problem
here you got a very coarse grain
structure in here
so i don't know if there was enough
tempering done on this 5160 blade
i mean one strike is all it took and
snapped it right in half
so that's obviously a problem
[Music]
well steve there's nothing left to test
your blade has suffered a catastrophic
failure and can no longer continue in
this competition
and for that reason i have to ask you to
please exit the forge
i'm upset i'm very disappointed that the
blade broke like that
i'm not coming home as a champion but
i'm coming home a whole lot smarter
i've made some friends that i'll have
forever i would do this again
no questions asked
well seth this is a competition where
the best blade wins your blade survived
this strength test
you are the forest and fire champion and
that's a title that comes with a check
for ten thousand dollars how do you feel
surreal right now
well good job brother you're a champion
i could not be more
excited about this experience this
competition has been some of the most
fun
of my life the money's going to do some
things for the shop and my wife
and my daughter are going to go on a
real nice trip
good job my name is seth boris and i'm
the forging fire champion
you